I have some very sad news to tell you
about today we've lost a number of big
fans of the show over the years when you
have an audience for a long enough
period of time sadly by mere math you're
going to lose some people to old age
you're going to lose some people to
disease you're going to lose some people
to accidents that happen and we've had
all of those and I've told you about
some of those stories Tracy got in touch
with me over the weekend the roommate of
a huge fan of the show
John Korra's who has passed away
after a long period of not not doing
well
John had spine afib Adele which is a
birth defect that affects the spine and
he was active and he was working up
until just a couple of years ago has
been a fan of the show for a really
really long time
and Tracy says that she and John would
regularly ask each other they were
roommates remember did you see the
latest David Pakman show clip did you
see this interview that David did did
you see that crazy right winger who
appeared on the show they would talk
about politics John was more libertarian
than Tracy but they both enjoyed the
show they would debate each other
respectfully they were really good
friends and both really good friends of
the show and just really really sad news
of John's passing but I'm glad that
Tracy got in touch
obviously condolences to Tracy and all
of John's family and friends financially
things were tough they did a GoFundMe
for John's funeral and burial costs and
thanks to John's family and friends they
hit and exceeded their goal which is a
really really great thing to hear and
you know it's impossible to know
everyone in the audience personally I
feel bad that it's things have just
exceeded my ability to respond to
everybody's messages every day about
politics about the show about whatever
but from what Tracy told me and what
everybody has written on John John's
GoFundMe clearly a really nice guy who
cared about people really liked the show
and would talk about it to family and
friends they knew about the show they
became fans and a real
sad day for the David Pakman show not
much else that we can say um other than
continued best wishes to everybody that
knew John and we will we will certainly
miss him we will take a quick break and
be back with more right after this